c'est sur la télévision numérique
terrestre est une véritable révolution
technologique qui va offrir aux
téléspectateurs 14 et sean brady
aujourd'hui les buts les caméras les
régit les téléviseurs sont déjà bien
mais les émetteurs transmettent toujours
les programmes sous forme de signal
analogique un système utilisé depuis
l'invention de la télévision mais qui
présente deux inconvénients
d'abord il est très sensible au parasite
et aux échos ensuite il aimait ça nous
pouvons à une seule chaîne par carole
tant numérisant le signal sous forme de
0 et 1 comme ceux qui utilisent des
ordinateurs
il devient possible de le traiter pour
réduire le volume d'informations à
transmettre
premier avantage s'y posera sur le coup
de fil tendu un pour chaque canal soit
potentiellement une trentaine d
second avantage la qualité
exceptionnelle de l'image de son
comparable à celle de la vérité
jusqu'ici sommes un cas lafleur avait
max et à la qualité numérique transmises
par le câble l'adsl ou le satellite
la tnt elle s'adresse aux 75% employés
uniquement équipés d'antenne râteau
cette année france 3 a investi 35
millions d'euros dans cette technique
pour l'instant pour avoir la qualité du
mairie il fallait avoir le satellite
or sur le satellite on n'avait pas de
programme enrichi et on va maintenant
grâce à la tnt à voir les programmes
régionaux en qualité numérique ce qui va
être une offre tout à fait spécifique
puisque nous sommes la seule offre
régionale en qualité numérique pour
traiter le signal reçu
il faut bien sûr placé un adaptateur
entre l'antenne et téléviseurs vendus
entre 80 et 130 euros
à l'avenir les appareils intégreront
directement cet adaptateur numérique
dans la plupart des cas les
installations individuelles n'auront pas
besoin de modification dans les
immeubles
une intervention de l'antenniste sera en
revanche souvent nécessaire coût
prévisible
une trentaine d'euros par appartement
dès le 31 mars 35 % des téléspectateurs
pourront capter cette tnt 50 % en
septembre et 65 % en 2006 pour savoir si
votre région est déjà équipé vous pouvez
consulter le site internet tnt tirer
gratuite point fr ou téléphoner au 08 90
64 2010